to the house on our companion network
c-span
now a look at the career of washington
d.c mayor marion barry
jeanetta rose barris discusses her book
the last of the black emperors the
hollow comeback of marion barry in the
new age of black leaders
ms barris is a columnist for the
washington times and a contributor to
several magazines
janetta rose barris you're the author of
a new book titled the last of the black
emperors
the hollow comeback of marion barry in
the new age of black leaders
when you sat down to write and research
this book what kind of reader did you
have in mind
i actually have a general reader in mind
one who doesn't necessarily
follow politics maybe someone who would
look at news articles and read them and
so i was more interested in
contextualizing marion barry um sort of
comparing him to other political figures
african-american political figures and
mainstream american political figures
so that
the average reader would see him
connected to something connected to a
cultural tradition
and connected to
an american political tradition because
i think a lot of people have looked at
marion barry as a unique sort of
an appendage
of the political process when he is
actually i think
an integral part of it and represents
what
american politics has become
where did marion barry grow up
in itabina south uh in italy mississippi
a southern small southern town actually
it's a little bit outside itabina uh on
a plantation his parents were
sharecroppers and uh picked cotton
and
and they were very very poor
his mother was 18 when she gave birth to
mary and barry and
his father
was 46
so there was a huge age difference
between them sort of i think though it
was in keeping with the times often
young women married older men believing
it was more stable but they had a pretty
rough life
what was his formal education
well now he he went to school uh and his
mother moved the family to memphis uh
they went from uh they went from itabina
to arkansas for a little while and then
they went to memphis and um so he went
to school in memphis and
then he went to lemoyne college
then he went to
fisk university in in nashville
tennessee um and uh where he was working
on
a master's degree in um
chemistry was getting a doctorate was
just a little shy of a doctor he did get
his master's
what year was he working on his
doctorate i was in the 1960s 67 i'm
sorry in the 19 early 60s around
57 60 somewhere around that time because
he came up here to washington in 1965.
was it unusual for a young black man at
the time to be
progressing towards a doctorate
no i don't think so i mean there were
quite a few blacks who had gotten
doctorates before that education was for
many blacks uh perceived as the thing
for advancing in american society i mean
you had somebody like w.b du bois who
had a doctorate in anna cooper who had a
doctorate so there were a number of of
uh well-known african-americans who had
doctorates um
i think it might have been strange to
have someone
uh
of marion barry's caliber going you know
it's a hard decision for him do i pursue
education do i pursue
the civil rights movement but it was not
unusual for african americans to really
struggle to go as high as they could
with their
with their
college educations you mentioned in your
book that he taught for a while where
did he teach and when did he stop
teaching well now he taught
in
louisville for a while
and
and left there and
it was only for one semester he was a
student teacher
and decided to come back
to
work in the movement and
went down to mississippi
for a while the movement was like his
summer what he would do on a summer
vacation
and um and so he went to
work on his doctorate and do student
teaching at the same time and then just
decided to abandon all that and just
focus on the civil rights movement
what is the s n c c and what was marion
barry's involvement in that group it's
it's pronounced snick and it's the
student nonviolent coordinating uh uh
committee and uh it was in sort of the
youth arm of the southern christian
leadership
council that uh
conference that
was started
with a number of ministers in the south
just after the uh boycott well just
after rosa parks actually refused to get
give up her seat on the bus in alabama
and the woman named ella baker thought
it would be very important involve youth
and so she called a bunch of
of young people who were involved in uh
civil rights activities marion barry was
in nashville at fisk with diane nash and
a number of other people and uh and john
lewis who is now in the in congress and
they were actually beginning to do some
things of their own so they were called
all of them went to north carolina and
out of that meeting
came the uh student uh came became snick
and
for uh i would imagine for uh the 1960s
the most of the 1960s snick was pretty
active toward the end of the 60s early
70s it began to just wane people started
it started having its own internal
strides
from the south how did marion barry come
to washington and why well now he was
very involved in voter registration down
in mississippi and
in uh decided and they also sent him to
do fundraising uh in the north for the
organization he he was obviously pretty
good at at raising money um and so
james foreman who was the secretary of
field secretary for snick at the time
decided that washington dc was sort of
ripe for organizing and marion barry was
actually sent
to washington to help organize a chapter
of snick and and you know sort of
stimulate some activity uh he got here
got involved uh actually
organized the first
bus boycott um
it was a one-day boycott in washington
in washington dc in 1965 um it was a
guy named olroy shark who owned the bus
company at that time many of the bus
companies across the country were
privately owned and um
so marionberry came there was some some
struggle to the bus company wanted to
raise the fare people were of course
opposed to that they were also they
didn't necessarily like the way they
were treated by the company and and the
the number of bus routes they had and
all of that and so there was a boycott
that was organized for one day it was
pretty successful and they held back the
uh the nickel increase but the guy
eventually got his nickel but marion
barry obviously built his career on that
particular successful
action
when was the first elected mayor of
washington d.c he was elected as the
second mayor the first mayor was walter
washington and marion barry was elected
in 1978 as the second mayor of
washington d.c and remained mayor until
1990 when sharon pratt kelly was elected
and then he of course
reappeared in 1994
um as the fourth as a well he was a
sort of it's hard to say whether he was
the fourth mayor but he
sort of uh
came back and and uh succeeded mary uh
sharon brad kelly
in your book you write about the 1994
election
what are some of the details how did
marion barry get elected in 1994 what
was different about that election i
don't think there was anything really
different about that election i think
the probably the thing that was
different was that he had been arrested
in 1990
um by the fbi in an fbi sting at the
vista hotel
where he was caught
with a woman who was not his wife in a
hotel room who
sort of
and and he was smoking or had just
put a crack pipe to his mouth
um and so no one thought after such an
international uh fall from grace that he
could possibly
return to political office
but he used some of the same strategy
and there was an animosity in washington
d.c about the way that
fbi sting actually occurred a lot of
people called it a setup one of the
things people were uh were angry over
was that here was mary and barry in a
room he had gone to see a woman
principally ostensibly to have sex and
and she actually uh kept suggesting to
him drugs and he kept saying no and she
kept suggesting and so people got the
general impression that he might not
have
smoked that crack pipe if she hadn't
pushed him into it as a sort of uh a
prelude to uh some some romantic
involvement and uh it was that animosity
then that was that work that he worked
to his advantage the other thing he
worked to his advantage was that there
there was this real epidemic in all
urban centers in america certainly in
washington dc with crack cocaine
middle class people rich people were
seeing their kids some members of their
family
cousins uncles sometimes husbands and
wives um sort of falling to this
particular drug which was one of the
most insidious drugs that had hit the
american market of late and so there was
some uh understanding of what marion
barry may have gone through and that
but for the grace of god it could have
been any one of them or in some
instances it was one of them and so they
were particularly i think sympathetic
to his struggle with drugs
and very angry and so you had that
combination of anger and sympathy
sort of rolling into one working with a
very seasoned politician who understood
the psychology of the city that he had
led for almost 16 12 16 years
what role did the press have in covering
marion barry
from the beginning of his mayoral
career and during this whole trial
about the drug situation oh well i think
that uh in the beginning
marion barry was seen in washington as a
savior
we the city was just coming into a kind
of quasi independence uh it had been
attached to a congress sort of working
as an agency of of
of of congress of the federal government
and
the congress under richard nixon had
finally awarded city the city what they
call home rule um
and limited home rule and so uh
he was seen as someone who could help
actually help structure a government
he came in with a cross-section of
people
gays whites blacks young's old
and and so he had a very good coalition
the washington post which was a major
newspaper at that time endorsed marion
barry and it was the washington post
endorsement that actually kicked him up
and and had him win against walter
washington and sterling tucker
and the washington post up until
right up almost up until the third about
the middle of his third term as mayor
the washington post uh pretty much
supported him but like the rest of the
city they became very disillusioned
when there were repeated rumors of his
drug use his womanizing he was caught um
and so
the post i think in this case with marin
barry the post and the other washington
media the washington times and black
media build him up
and yet
and i would have to say that they paid a
a a strong role in his uh decline
in your book you write about the
washington post and i wanted to read one
of the sentences
that you wrote about the 1994 coverage
the washington post went after barry
with a vengeance covering his campaign
like white on rice
wherever he went reporters were there
and what the news pages missed the
editorial pages picked up on it was an
awesome assault that only an omnipotent
institution like the post could mount
what did you mean by that sentence well
um i think that they were all over them
it was like a michael jordan kind of
thing
and that um
the washington post has the luxury of
having
as many as
uh 25 reporters they can assign to cover
one story in a minute
and so
you have to remember that they had
endorsed sharon pratt kelly marion
barry's predecessor or the incumbent in
that race they had endorsed this woman
in three different uh endorsements on
the editorial page she was their
candidate to actually clean up the city
now she performed very poorly but they
also did not want marion barry to return
and so
the the washington post staff then
went after finding the facts and finding
out whether marion barry was actually
redeemed had was he using drugs what was
he doing in his personal life
that could affect his professional uh
career and his professional life and the
editorial pages the columnist and the
editorial page itself were critically
looking at what he could offer
a lot of people in the city and i think
the media
could be
accused of this as well were concerned
about
what would a return of marion barry do
to the city's relationship with congress
which was already kind of frayed from
his previous tenure and did not get much
better under sharon pratt kelly
i wanted to mention a couple names
uh and just have you described for us
mary and barry's relationship with these
people
one name is reverend jesse jackson are
they friends are they foes what's their
relationship i think that at one point
that they were friends
um
one in in 1994 well in 1990 where there
was talk of marion of jesse jackson
running against marion barry there
marion barry made the comment that the
only thing jess is going to do is run
his mouth the only way
so there there is that kind of
competitive uh
relationship that they have they both
were in the movement together but
clearly jesse jackson was much closer to
um to the reverend martin luther king
than than marion barry
at this point i think that there is a
healthy but distant respect for each
other
how about andrew brimmer who is andrew
brimmer what's their relationship andrew
brimmer is the director of the
d.c financial responsibility and
management assistance authority commonly
called the control board here which was
created by congress and
created by congress in march 1995
to actually
help the city to
sort of
work its way out of the financial crisis
much like a control board was created
for new york and a control board created
for philadelphia when those cities
faced
the brink of insolvency and financial
and management crises um and so andrew
bremer is the chairman of that board now
what's interesting about andrew bremer
and marion barry is they are probably
very from the same era in that
and from the same region
and similar experiences andrew bremer
grew up in louisiana in a sharecropper
kind of experience as well and worked
his way all the way up to become
a member of the federal board on an
economist
and very highly respected international
credentials
marion barry
from mississippi grows up to become a
rebel rouser community organizer and
politician
in the tradition of the south
andrew bremer would probably be
respected far more
simply because of his educational
credentials but also because of his
sense of of uh dignified presence that
he presents which uh african americans
still sort of admire there's this cool
reserve
that i speak about in the book that you
never
ever let um
anyone else understand that they have
ruffled your feathers and i think andrew
bremer is sort of the same coin
marionberry and andrew bremer the same
coin just different sides of it
how many times has marion barry been
married and tell us about his
his wives who's he married to now he's
married to cora masters
he married her just as he was coming
into office right after leaving a
federal penitentiary for the
conviction of drug possession
he married her in 1993
he became a ward 8 council member city
council member the same year
and she was someone who had supported
him for a very long time
back in the 80s
and was a friend of the family is
how my sources tell me and um developed
a relationship with him while he was
still married was she the one on the
boxing commission yes she was the
chairman of the boxing commission for a
while and there was this was back in the
early 1980s and there was a bit of a
problem with her tenure where she was
accused of double dipping charging the
city for expenses and charging the
federal boxing commission for um the
federation of boxing commission for um
for the same uh expenses um she
uh
pleaded guilty to avoid um
actual jail time and and prosecution and
repaid the money
um and so
she obviously was taken off the boxing
commission but she and the mayor
remained very good friends and he made
sure she had access to that and she
still
um remains pretty active in that in that
industry
prior to her was
effie
cowell cowell rather who was a teacher
economics teacher at one time in health
and economics teacher in new york
came to washington met marion barry um
while he was still married to his second
wife
marion barry began an affair with her
he eventually
began living with her and just before he
became before he decided to run for
mayor he and his and effie were married
they had a child christopher who is um
on his way to
college
this year will be his last year and
he'll be attending hampton university is
what his dad says
um
effie and um effie kawal and
and marion barry were divorced just
after the
the end of the trial uh the drug
possession trial and she was the third
wife
she was actually yes his third wife okay
now the second wife was mary treadwell
whom he met while he was in the south
but did not become socially or
connected to until he
came up here to washington dc she was
already here in washington
she was very active and involved with
him in community activities they
co-founded along with carol harvey and
catfish mayfield an organization called
pride youth pride inc which was pretty
innovative at the time that they did
this back in the 70s
um it was actually the late 60s early
70s when the organization was at its
height and it was designed to take what
we would what some of us might call
street dudes or thugs off the street
give them real skills help them create
businesses which they did and was very
successful for a time
and she was the first wife the first
wife was
blanti evans
whom he met while he was in college and
divorced
shortly thereafter
she divorced him actually accused him of
desertion
principally because he was actually
married to the revolution as some people
might say
because he spent most of his time in the
civil rights movement didn't have time
for a wife and probably realized when he
did it that it was a big mistake
did you attend his 1995 inaugural that
you described where my angelou read yes
poetry
it was at the uh d.c um
university of the district of columbia
in their gymnasium a very uh
sort of
this exuberance was just you know like
something phenomenal had happened and so
everybody was very excited um and
marion barry maya angelou read this poem
by
um sterling brown strong man which
strong men which actually sort of charts
the life of african americans in this
country from slavery their struggle
through jim crow and and and their
amazing resilience and
reading that poem she then connected
marion barry's life and recent struggle
uh and rise again with that kind of
philosophy which
sort of
really gave him i think much more
currency and credentials than he
probably deserved but nonetheless it was
an exciting moment it was a very
emotional moment for him for his wife
her son
to see
that a man who had fallen so low
was now
picked up and placed on the shoulders of
this city much the way um football
players would do a winning coach
and um and it was uh an amazing
show of forgiveness from a community i
thought
in your book
your subtitle is the hollow comeback of
marion barry
do you view his comeback as hollow
and tell us more about your subtitle
well
the book actually looks at uh
not only his rise uh from the prison the
federal prison and and and what happened
to get him back into political office in
city council and then the mayoral seat
but it looks at
the substance of that rise and that's
where the hollow comeback comes from the
substance of what he did in 1992 is a
city council member representing one of
the city's
more
underserved and poor populations he
actually
in my view and from the facts did very
little for those people during the one
year that he was actually representing
them he basically used them as pawns in
a step stone a stepping stone to his uh
struggle to get back his mayor's seat
as mayor just coming in
realizing that he's facing
about a 700 million dollar cumulative
deficit projected deficit um
put this
put the sort of the cap on his ability
to rise any higher than just being
reelected because it put into uh work
the
in
the creation of a control board and um
and then the removal of power that
subsequently uh went along with that and
so while he may have thought that coming
into office uh would give him the
opportunity to
reshape his legacy and reposition
himself as a major power in
african-american political history in
fact what it did was to
make him completely impotent
for the book did you interview him no he
refused uh to participate in the book
why um
well now i don't know why um
he said well i don't know what you're
going to write well you never know what
a reporter or a journalist or writer is
going to write but i think he also is
planning to write his own book
i think he understood that i was coming
to this story with a wealth of
information i've been covering the city
since 1984.
for uh for the washington afro-american
and then later the washington times and
then later washington city paper
and so i fairly know marion barry and
marion barry isms
and mary bear and barry speaks and you
know and all these little uh kind of
techniques political techniques that
politicians use and become attached to
them are you a conservative no i'm not
um i consider myself an independent and
uh and i think i have mary and barry to
thank for that because i at one time uh
in 1982 actually went to work for his
campaign as assistant to his uh to the
press person the press secretary for his
second term
and uh grew disillusioned with the
organization of that campaign although
he did win
and later i worked for time in the
district government as a consultant
and
it was so it was seeing
various things up close
that i was able to realize that i could
not just attach
i could not attach my endorsement and
support to a politician simply because
he was black
and i think that a number of
african-americans throughout this
country have done that and so
the book which talks about the new age
of black leaders
goes right to that the broader theme of
the book is to
sort of assess
what we as african-americans must do
uh if we are going to really be
politically empowered in this country
and part of it is to objectively
evaluate our leaders not just to
stand behind them and support everything
they do simply because they're black um
and so my independence then comes from
my understanding that uh everything that
everything black is not always gold
i have two final questions 20 30 years
from now
when people look back at the history of
washington dc and marion barry
what will his legacy be
i think the main thing that people will
remember about marion barry is that he
helped
in a very dramatic way to expand the
middle class here
and in uh and and also to explain expand
the middle class and pg county uh prince
george's county which is you know
adjacent to washington dc as a suburb is
now one of the more wealthy and better
educated suburbs in the country and and
predominantly black and many of those
people lived in washington worked for
marion barry worked for the district
government
marion barry did a great deal to to help
to create that middle class
is he going to run again in 1998 and if
he does would you vote for him
i don't expect him to run again in 1998
i think uh that marion barry understands
that with the control board he will have
no power until the year 2002 and
congress may be inclined to strip him of
the last few little agencies that he
currently has power over so i expect him
to go out quietly and to sort of
repackage himself and to say
these are all the things that i've done
and um and i think i've done a good job
janetta rose barris we thank you for
coming into c-span to talk to us about
the last of the black emperors the
hollow comeback of marion barry in the
new age of black leaders published